today we face the monsters that are at
our door today we are
hey youtubers I just thought I'd do a
review of Pacific Rim I just loved it so
much and it is robot porn at its finest
is it art or is it porn let's discuss
just kidding
I feel though like it's the movie that
sci-fi lovers have been waiting for all
year it's an original movie that is it's
not a sequel and it's not adapted
material and Guillermo del Toro does
these amazing creature movies and this
essentially is a giant robot giant
creature movie like a kaiju film like
Godzilla and like I said even though it
obviously is a lot of giant robots like
we've seen in the trailers I feel like
the movie really is all about the
monsters the kaiju monsters kaiju
literally means monster in Japanese it
obviously pays a lot of homage to
Japanese monster films but that being
said the monsters are the real stars of
this movie and I think that really comes
across in a lot of gear Motel Toros
movies have you seen a lot of other
Guillermo del Toro movies like Pan's
Labyrinth and the Hellboy movies then
you'll know he does practical creature
effects in such an awesome way in
Pacific Rim we actually get to see a lot
of kaijus you know up close and because
they're done as practical effects it
just looks so amazing obviously they're
enhanced a little bit with CG but he
actually built parts of a lot of these
monsters so it just adds this really
nice texture to the film but hey it's
not about the kaijus out there it's all
about the kaijus in here the big money
shot for me was a monster I named
Japanese guide your films that's what it
was about if you can imagine a crocodile
and a lizard
okay well lizard is the dinosaur and the
crocodile is the guy a lot of people
online I feel have been comparing this
movie to Evangelion but in Evangelion
it's all about the bond between the
pilot and the cyborg or the giant mech
and in this movie it's actually about
the bond between the two pilots so it's
Charlie Hunnam from sons of anarchy and
Rinko Kikuchi and obviously a lot of
other things I don't a spoil happen in
the movie before they come together as
this pair but it's not really a romance
it's about the melding of two people to
become one and working together if you
want something to prime you for this
movie just watch a lot of the scenes in
Hellboy
- like the scene in the marketplace
where he does all these practical
creature effects imagine those just at
you know massive Godzilla size like I
said I feel like this film benefits from
practical effects so much more if you
remember a lot of films like
transformers that are so obviously CG I
feel like those kinds of effects really
take me out of the story it's like it's
like you really understand the what
you're watching is not real and it's so
much easier to believe a story when you
feel like you could reach out and touch
it or it could touch you back legs
overall I give the movie and a - it's
just because I felt like the execution
was so great there were just a few
unnecessary action scenes that I feel
like worked really well maybe in the
story phase that just didn't translate
quite as well - being on screen for
instance there's this one scene where
they're basically fighting at the bottom
of the ocean and if you remember at the
bottom of the ocean there's really no
light so it's super dark so it's like
it's like watching a big fight take
place in total darkness so I feel like
that was a little bit unnecessary but I
feel like when they were constructing
the story they wanted to show basically
these monsters they come out of this
undersea rift so they wanted a battle to
take place on the ocean floor and while
the idea of fighting a giant monster on
the floor of the ocean is really cool
and practice you really wouldn't see any
of the action so it just was a little
bit silly I felt like all the actors
performances were great I haven't
watched any Sons of Anarchy but after
watching Charlie Hunnam in this I
actually got a little bit interested so
I might check it out
Rinko Kikuchi is awesome as his partner
she is a badass she's definitely not a
love interest in this movie she's not
like someone that needs to be rescued
guillermo del toro made this big deal
about her being this really powerful
force and having this really well
developed character remember it's all
about the bond between these two
characters it's not really about like a
romance between them and ITER's Alba
kicks butt as always I feel like I
haven't seen a movie with him recently
where he plays someone who just isn't
amazing Charlie Day and Ron Perlman
actually played the comedic relief in
the movies I feel like they do a great
job so if you haven't seen a lot of
Charlie Day stuff watch Always Sunny so
now let's talk a little bit about the
sequel it's actually in development
currently obviously a lot will depend on
how well this movie does
at the box office and in DVD sales but
guillermo del toro has already said that
they're developing a story and based on
some of the events in the movie we can
kind of guess on what that movie is
going to deal with so if you don't want
to hear anything or any spoilers or
potential spoilers for the sequel be
sure to turn the volume down now
it's like I said the stars of this movie
are the kaiju monsters it turns out
they're actually these
alternate-dimension descendants of
dinosaurs that are super smart so
they're basically attacking all these
people on earth and Cod's and all this
devastation with a specific plan in mind
so the sequel is obviously going to
develop more of their story and maybe
there might even be the possibility that
the humans might go through the rift at
the bottom of the Pacific Rim into their
dimension I don't really think that's
the case just because realistically the
CG would just cost so much money but
obviously any sequel would really
develop the kaiju monsters history a lot
more than it has in this movie really
when we meet them it's kind of in the
middle of their attack so obviously we
find a lot more about their evolution
twenty-day places scientists in the
movie and it's his job basically to tell
us is the audience all the technical
info we need to know to understand what
the kaiju monsters are so let me know
what you think though write in the
comments are we going to see a Pacific
Rim sequel and what did you think of
this movie if you've seen it honestly I
really love seeing original sci-fi
movies and I think we all need to go
support this movie just so Hollywood
learns that original stories are just as
good as sequels so if you don't want 20
other sequels next year be sure to spend
money on movie tickets personally I'll
be seeing it at least twice I'm paying
I haven't snuck into a movie since I was
about 14 remember the real monster this
weekend though is Adam Sandler's
grown-up's to teen Pacific Rim do not go
see that at the movie seriously it's
terrible in the meantime you can check
out a bunch of my Comic Con previews by
clicking here and you can learn all
about what Joss Whedon's is up to with
Avengers 2 and Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch by clicking here thanks for
watching tons of Comic Con videos coming
up soon be sure to check out Pacific Rim
and get pumped for Comic Con next week
I'm gonna be posting a shitload of
videos it's gonna be amazing
high fives
you